Speaker 1: Let's speak to a few more
people today via discord. We take calls
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
If you would like to chat, just raise
your hand. It's very simple. We're going to go
to Ricardo from Montreal, Canada. Of course,
in the province of Quebec. Ricardo, welcome
to the program. What is on your mind today as
you get all of your various technical issues
that I can tell you are having sorted out?
Ricardo from Montreal, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Hi. Perfect. Hi, David. This is my first time
ever calling on any show ever, Like, every like,
calling or using discord. So I'm actually kind of
nervous right now. And. And this is my first time
ever doing a call on this call, so.
Speaker 1: Well,
let's make it a good one. Ricardo, please.
Speaker 3: Yes, so I do. And so I know that,
um, I'm actually been following your show since
2020. I've been listening to every single episode
on your show since 2020. I'm actually a long time
listener, and I just want to ask you a question
because I know I know you said time and time and
time and time again that humans are really bad at
predicting future events. Yeah, but how likely
do you think it's going to happen, that America
is going to become a right wing dictatorship?
Speaker 1: I have I have no idea. You know, the
thing about these questions, Ricardo, is remember
during the State of the Union addresses when Trump
was president and he would say, America will never
be a socialist country. Do you remember that?
Speaker 3: I think so. I think, uh, I don't
know. I was probably thinking 2020 or 20. 21,
I think.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess. Yeah. 2019 or in
any case, and I would say Trump is right that
America is not about to be a socialist country.
There's no risk of that. There's no socialists
in position of power, etc.. So one of the things
Trump's doing is he's trying to overstate
the risk of a socialist country, but never,
never is a very long time. I think that's
a very dumb prediction to make. 500 years,
100,000? Who who knows? You know. So will America
be a right wing dictatorship? I have absolutely no
idea. It depends on the decisions that are made.
And me giving you an answer, a definitive answer
would be nothing better than just a wild guess.
Could America become a right wing dictatorship?
Absolutely. Is it closer now than it was? I don't
know, 15 years ago? I think the answer is yes. But
I beyond that, I don't know.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm. Yeah,
that makes sense. That's a total valid
answer, but I'm just. I'm just, like,
asking this question because it's really just
from a perspective of a concerned Canadian.
Yes. We're watching. We're watching here from
a pier, and we realize what's what's happening
and every single day. And it really just
concerns the heck out of this. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I would be concerned, too. And listen,
you can be a little less concerned than if you're
in the United States. So at least you have that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's fair. That's. But I just
really wish all the best for you guys. And
I just hope that you guys are able to, like,
sort out everything that's going on there. Like,
I just really wish the best because that. That
just really, really seems very concerning.
And I appreciate so normal. I don't know
how long it will take. Maybe like ten years,
20 years, but we'll see because I know that
75 million people voted for Trump in 2020. Right.
And and there's still, like millions and millions
of people that still follow Donald Trump. And
who are he still is ardent supporters that will
defend him no matter what?
Speaker 1: Very much.
Speaker 3: So. But and look at the I guess
with the 2022 midterms, that was kind of
a good sign because it just showed a bit like
the the waning power of the Trump MAGA movement.
But we'll see. We'll see what happens
in like 2024, especially with all the
troubles that Trump is facing right now.
Speaker 1: I hope so. I hope so. Ricardo,
listen. Saint Viator or Fairmont
Bagel? Which do you prefer in Montreal?
Speaker 3: Savita.
Speaker 1: You think it's better?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think so.
Speaker 1: Okay. And have
you ever been to Tommy for brunch?
Speaker 3: Oh, boy. Sure has millions and millions
of restaurants, so I don't think I have. Okay.
Speaker 1: I don't know about millions of
restaurants, but I recommend it.
Check it out. It's a good spot. All
right. Get the eggs Benedict. Thank you.
Speaker 3: I'm exaggerating, but I know
there's there's quite a few, but I heard that
this interesting statistic that apparently if
you were to visit every single restaurant, I
think three times a day for the next 18 years,
you would take that amount of time to visit
every single restaurant in history, I believe.
Speaker 1: I believe it. Ricardo, I will be
back in Montreal soon and I look forward to it.
Speaker 3: Yeah. All right. Well,
we'll be happy to have you back.
Speaker 1: All right, Ricardo from Montreal, great
to hear from you. Very, very much. Appreciate it.